[Musique]
bonjour jean luc c'est arnaud montebourg
à
parlons nous à 90 mélenchon n'en est pas
là
[Musique]
mais
surtout
[Rires]
au
bout
[Musique]
c'est le double j'en coup de gueule je
commande des arts potes sur la fnac le
site la fnac écoutez bien je reçois ceux
ci ok je joue je déballe je reçois bien
donc dès que ça donc j'ai pas de câble
pour charger donc j'ai désormais de
change j'ai bien au boîtier et j'ai bien
ça je suis dit c'est bizarre je vais
voir la fneeq ce qui me manque le cadre
lorsque je monte mon modèle avec ma
référence tous cas là le mec me dire un
merci monsieur c'est normal sur les
reconditionner charme et pourquoi je
paye le prix fort pour des
reconditionnés c'est quoi cette arnaque
donc je lui demande s'il peut les
reprendre et que moi je vais commander à
la fnac et me dit non c'est pas possible
on reprend pas voilà donc la fnac médias
parce que c'est une belle arnaque on
vous dit pas quand sarkozy c'est ce qui
s'est écrit nulle part j'ai cherché
partout donc tu paye le prix fort pour
des reconditionnés sympa la fnac merci
les gars voilà je vous fais de la fois
de la pub est franchement de la fnac
c'est l'arnaqué
m
est ce un signe
[Musique]
c'est humain
alors bref oui
oui bah ouais
[Musique]